Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
With the recent ascendancy of neural network-based
techniques, we have witnessed amazing algorithms
that are able to take an image from a video
game and translate it into reality and the
other way around.
Or, they can also translate daytime images
to their nighttime versions, or change summer
to winter and back.
Some AI-based algorithms can also create near
photorealistic images from our sketches.
So the first question is, how is this wizardry
even possible?
These techniques are implemented by using
Generative Adversarial Networks, GANs in short.
This is an architecture where two neural networks
battle each other: the generator network is
the artist who tries to create convincing,
real-looking images.
The discriminator network is the critic that
tries to tell a fake image from a real one.
The artist learns from the feedback of the
critic and will improve itself to come up
with better quality images, and in the meantime,
the critic also develops a sharper eye for
fake images.
These two adversaries push each other until
they both become adept at their tasks.
However, the training of these GANs is fraught
with difficulties.
For instance, it is not guaranteed that this
process converges to a point, and therefore
it matters a great deal when we stop training
the networks.
This makes reproducing some works very challenging
and is generally not a desirable property
of GANs.
It is also possible that the generator starts
focusing on a select set of inputs and refuses
to generate anything else, a phenomenon we
refer to as mode collapse.
So how could we possibly defeat these issues?
This work presents a technique that mimics
the steps of evolution in nature: evaluation
and selection and variation.
First, this means that not one, but many generator
networks are trained, and only the ones that
provide sufficient quality and diversity in
their images will be preserved.
We start with an initial population of generator
networks, and evaluate the fitness of each
of them.
The better and more diverse images they produce
more fit they are, the more fit they are,
the more likely they are to survive the selection
step where we eliminate the most unfit candidates.
Okay, so we now see how a subset these networks
become the victim of evolution.
This is how networks get eaten, if you will.
But, how do we produce new ones?
And this is how we arrive to the variation
step, where new generator networks are created
by introducing variations to the networks
that are still alive in this environment.
This simulates the creation of an offspring,
and will provide the next set of candidates
for the next selection step, and we hope that
if we play this game over a long time, we
get more and more resilient offsprings.
The resulting algorithm can be trained in
a more stable way, and it can create new bedroom
images when being shown a database of bedrooms.
When compared to the state of the art, we
see that this evolutionary approach offers
higher quality images and more diversity in
the outputs.
It can also generate new human faces that
are quite decent.
They are clearly not perfect, but a technique
that can pull this off consistently will be
an excellent baseline for newer and better
research works in the near future.
We are also getting very close to an era where
we can generate thousands of convincing digital
characters from scratch to name just one application.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!